my wife almost died in 2009 from a
chronic illness it eventually led her to
the hospital for six days and I was just
in a place of course wondering like why
is this happening how are we going to
pay for medical bills and one day when
she was sleeping in the hospital room I
walked to Barnes and Noble across the
street and I find a book called crush it
by Gary vaynerchuk
[Music]
I grab it I go back to the hospital room
and I read the entire thing I had one
big takeaway
I need to go crush it his impact in my
life is so significant that there really
wouldn't be a think media had there not
been that initial spark to get me going
in this direction